اذا اسرائيل تعرف الكثير في ديسمبر 2018
كشفت وثائقي للمعارضه الايرانيه اخفاء
حكومه طهران مواقع عسكريه سريه الى جانب
المواقع الخمسه المعلنه لطنز اراك اشكار
اباد واشيان لفيسان وفوردو الوثائق التي
قدمت لصحيفه البريطانيه اظهرت وجود اربع
منشات شاركت في جوانب مختلفه من المشروع
النووي وشملت مواقع في باجهش كاده في مجمع
برشين العسكري وموقع نوري الصناعي الواقع
في مجمع حجير العسكري وهفتير في قاعده
تحمل نفس الاسم وسانجريانا بالقرب من مجمع
بارشي واحين جاء كشف اصفهان من قبل
نتنياهو لم يكن ذلك مفاجئا فاصبهان مركز
صناعه الصواريخ الايرانيه لكن هي ايضا تضم
مصنعا لتخصيب اليورانيوم واخر لانتاج
اجهزه الطرد المتطوره ومصنعا للمسيرات
والذي ينتج بالمناسبه شاهد 136 المستخدمه
في اوكرانيا لكن لماذا كان الهدف مصنع
الصواريخ حصرا الاجابه واضحه لتل ابيب
ولها اولوياتها الصواريخ كما ذكرناه هي
معادله النووي الايراني اكبر الاخطار
بالنسبه لاسرائيل وبحسب تصنيف استراتيجي
تصنيفا استراتيجي لمعهد الدراسات الامن
القوميه الاسرائيلي تنقل صحيفه معاريف عن
تمير هيمان ورئيسه هو ايضا رئيس
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاسرائيليه السابق
تنقل امرا اخر مثيرا للاهتمام يقول هيمان
انه اوصى نتنياهو بالخطوه الدراماتيكيه
الاخيره في الصندوق الغربي تدمير الاتفاق
النووي بالكامل بالانسحاب الاوروبي منه
عواقب ذلك طبعا معروفه اعاده فرض اليه
سناب باك عقوبات مجلس الامن لكن من تقلق
هذه الخطوه امريكا لانها تخشى الرد
الايراني والكلام هنا لا يزال اليهمان
[موسيقى]
ونعود الى الخطوه الدراماتيكيه التي
اتحدثنا عنها والتي اوصت بها تل ابيب اوصى
بها المعهد للامن القومي نتنياهو اذا
الاجابه هنا عن هذه الخطوه ليست في تل
ابيب بل في واشنطن ولدى روبرت مالي
المبعوث الامريكي لايران وبتاكيده ان
بلاده وحلفائها الاوروبيين متحدون اليوم
في مواجهه ايران اكثر مما كانت عليه الحال
في السابق ايران التي باتت قريبه جدا جدا
من الحصول على كميه كافيه من اليورانيوم
المخصب بانتاج سلاح نووي ابي حسب مالي اما
عن كم هي قريبه من الحصول على القنبله
فهذا سؤال اخر اجابه مالي بالاتي ان ذلك
يستوجب وقتا اطول واذا اقتربت هذه الخطوه
فالمعطيات لدى الولايات المتحده ستتغير
ذكر اعمال بقول الرئيس بايدن اذا فشل
الاتفاق فكل الخيارات الاخرى على والعسكري
اهمها بالطبع لكنه رفض تاكيد تصريح بايدن
الاكثر اهميه الذي يتعلق بموت الاتفاق
النووي
فيديو
[موسيقى]